[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: Over the past decade,
record sales in on the rise.
So in the age music
streaming and downloading,
who's still listening to vinyl?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ADIA DOUGLAS: After school,
my parents come get me.
And then they take the right
here, and I open the store.
I do my little routine.
I put on record.
I am 16 years old.
I am in the 11th grade.
I started collecting when
I was about 10 years old.
My dad gave me a couple
problems to start out with.
My top finger out what
is my collection right
now are Oracular
Spectacular by MGMT,
Deja Vu by Crosby,
Stills, Nash, and Young,
and Warpaint by Warpaint.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When I'm listening to
my music on my stereo,
it just sounds better.
It sounds more alive.
There's like a totally different
vibe then we put in my laptop
on and playing
something from YouTube,
or Pandora, or Spotify.
JASON DOUGLAS: There's
nothing tangible to it.
You have these binary
ones and zeroes,
and that's what you have.
So I think everyone sacrificed
sonic quality for convenience.
ADIA DOUGLAS: My dad has
been such a great influence
on me loving vinyl, so much
that I had to open this place.
He's just always collected
records way before I was born.
I got the idea that we could
open a record store, because I
remembered we have
a bunch of boxes
full at the house of records
that were just sitting there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JASON DOUGLAS: One of
the biggest influences
over the past, I think,
five or six years
has been Record Store Day.
This is what got
Adia into wanting
to be a part of this generation
of new kids collecting vinyl.
You also have other
outlets selling more now.
Amazon, it's much more
tangible through them.
The internet has made the
world a much smaller place.
So you have much
more access to music
than I did when
I was a teenager.
ADIA DOUGLAS: Many teenagers
are definitely getting back
into listening to vinyl.
I have 13-year-old coming in,
saving their allowance just
by a bunch records,
which is really cool.
When their parents are
pulling out their old vinyl,
they're really getting into the
bands they're playing for them.
It's really great because
I've been into that,
so now I can relate to
all the kids my age.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: Has the internet
renewed your interested vinyl
records?
Let us know in the
comments below.
And to learn more about memes
and how they've evolved,
check out this video here.
SUBJECT 1: One of the earliest
instances is "Kilroy was Here."
It's this piece of graffiti that
was popularized in World War II
by American soldiers.
So when new soldiers
came through,
they knew that their
people had been there.
NARRATOR: Thanks
for watching, and be
sure to subscribe for
more Seeker Stories.